[Musique]
Véronique prince que l'on retrouve
Chantal Hébert Michel soget bonsoir
bonsoir bon je disais que la politique
et le théâtre c'est jamais très loin
parfois c'est peut-être quand même une
scène dont on va se souvenir aujourd'hui
à Québec Paul saint-pierre-la-mondon ému
on le voit là Véronique Xavier raison
émue presque au larmes oui qui attendait
que Dieu attendent avec ces deux
collègues un certain nombre de minutes
parce qu'il y a eu un retard à
l'intérieur du salon bleu et finalement
ils se sont comme prévu ça c'était prévu
aussi c'était écrit dans la pièce ils
allaient se faire dire non parce que ils
n'ont pas prêté serment je fais entendre
ce qui était pas avec nous au tout début
monsieur Paul Saint-Pierre permanent
qu'ils ont fait avancer tout ça sur le
groupe on revient en parler
on fait avancer les choses en l'espace
d'une semaine seulement on a réussi à
rallier toutes les partis politiques
pour que ça change hier le Parti libéral
du Québec dit qu'il voulait que ça
change donc une fois qu'on est rendu là
on a une personne ici qui fait son
travail
il faut travailler dans l'institution
dans le respect des gens
moi le premier j'aime pas ça prêter
serment au roi on est tous d'accord pour
abolir ce serment là la semaine
prochaine on va déposer un projet de loi
pour abolir le serment au roi donc moi
je pense la priorité actuellement c'est
de travailler à aider les Québécois à
faire face à l'inflation si pour le
Parti québécois il y a tôt priorité
c'est leur choix
je commence avec vous Michel C ils ont
réussi à aller au bout il y aura un
projet de loi il sera voté d'ici
vraisemblablement deux semaines fin de
l'histoire donc ce filon là aura profité
au PQ là
si il a gagné juste à rentrer vu que il
pourrait voter sur cette loi-là s'il le
voulait si ce qui malaise dans toute
cette histoire là c'est pas le fond de
l'affaire il y a pas grand monde qui
pense que le serment roi est une chose
extrêmement importante à conserver c'est
l'exagération qui avait qu'ils ont mis
avec là le parjure tous ceux qui ont
prêté serment l'être des parjure ah oui
tous les pékistes ça va vous en fait des
pagesjures c'est pas très élégant c'est
tout ce qui est exagéré était signifié
monsieur Parisot qui a aussi passé par
juré c'est ça l'affaire il y avait de
l'exagération là-dedans il y avait
beaucoup de théâtre peut-être un petit
peu trop Chantal point d'orgue
aujourd'hui de cette histoire il a été
très poli il a quand même il faut le
souligner pour certains pendant avec la
greffière bon de comprendre il était
presque mal à l'aise lui-même dans cette
pièce qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
aujourd'hui
qui le serait pas je suis pas convaincu
que de rentrer maintenant c'est
essentiel c'est eux qui se suivent de
beauté on s'entend là-dessus mais
néanmoins de fêter que la discussion a
avancée et qu'elle a avancé plus vite
parce que Québec solidaire était contre
socialement parce que le Parti québécois
l'été aussi et parce qu'on assiste ce
qui va se passer maintenant que la reine
n'est plus parce que ça aussi ça rentre
dans dans ce mélange là mais c'est quand
même intéressant moi ce que j'ai trouvé
de plus intéressant pour la scène
d'aujourd'hui c'est la rapidité tardive
du Parti libéral à découvrir que leur
première bataille dans notre nouvelle
Assemblée nationale pour défendre la
monarchie c'était peut-être pas l'idée
du siècle ça Véronique le tournant a eu
lieu hier soir presque en hier soir hier
après-midi juste avant le discours
inaugural de Monsieur le Gaulle les
libéraux ont dit mais savez-vous la nuit
a porté conseil on ne va on ne va pas
demander une commission on va pas
demander créer une prolongation et donc
ça aurait voulu dire que ça aurait pas
pu être réglé avant fin janvier ils vont
ils vont accélérer comme Chantal il
voulait pas être le seul parti opposé à
tout ça probablement aussi qui veulent
en quelque part couper court là à la
visibilité que le Parti québécois
obtient avec tout ça là qu'on met fin
puis qu'on passe à autre chose
finalement là parce que même si on en
parle vous savez le dicton parlez-en
bien par les anormales mais par les gens
là c'est un peu ça Paul Saint-Pierre
flamandon avait un déficit de notoriété
et dans le dernier mois c'est quand même
assez exceptionnel niveau communication
je pense c'est quand même un coup de
maître d'avoir réussi à faire parler
autant d'eux même si ça peut parfois
être négatif ils sont quand même juste
trois là à l'Assemblée nationale et
c'est très difficile surtout dans une
semaine de rentrer parlementaire où tout
est tourné vers le Premier ministre et
son discours d'ouverture de se démarquer
et par les uns américains par exemple il
y a quelques années quand ils étaient
trois Québec solidaires et même il a été
seul pendant un bout de temps à mercadir
il faisait à peu près 8 points de Prince
par jour il y avait aucun journaliste
qui était dans la salle donc c'est dur
de se démarquer ils ont réussi à le
faire maintenant le défi ça va être de
réussir en janvier aussi de faire parler
d'eux autant pour d'autres sujets ouais
c'est ça parce qu'une fois qu'on a vu la
pièce on peut pas la faire rejoindre
éternellement très bien
relation avec Ottawa c'est intéressant
Chantal vous en parliez hier sur
l'immigration changement
dans la revendication de monsieur
Legault face au fédéral il y a la santé
dont on va parler dans une seconde mais
commençons à par l'immigration je vous
fais écouter monsieur Legault là-dessus
on en parle
il y a un sujet qui est urgent ce sont
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui entre par le chemin Roxane c'est pas
normal que ça soit seulement le Québec
qui doivent assumer les coûts parce
qu'il y a des coûts aussi manque de
logement manque de service en santé en
éducation et saviez-vous comment ça
prend de temps avant que le gouvernement
fédéral
juste la personne est une vraie ou non
réfugiée politique ça prend deux ans et
là il est temps d'abord que le
gouvernement fédéral nous rembourse ces
couleurs puis deuxièmement il est temps
qui réduisent des délais troisièmement
payer temps qui renégocie l'entente avec
les États-Unis pour les pays tiers
ça c'est le contre exemple c'est le
chemin Roxane ou monsieur le Gaudi là on
a des demandes à faire très précis mais
pour le reste il s'est dit hier très
ouvert avec le fédéral négocié les
migration économique et la cité sur le
l'aspect francophone Chantal Hébert
qu'est-ce que ça augure comme
négociation avec Ottawa sur
l'immigration
ça augure pas vraiment beaucoup de
négociation avec Ottawa sur
l'immigration parce qu'en clair ce que
monsieur Legault a dit hier c'est ce que
le gouvernement fédéral dit c'est à dire
on n'est pas encore allé jusqu'au bout
des pouvoirs qu'on a pour déterminer la
sorte d'immigration qu'on veut
accueillir et on va s'en servir pour que
ce soit essentiellement des francophones
sur le chemin Roxane sérieusement si le
gouvernement canadien réussissait
convaincre les États-Unis de renégocier
l'entente ce serait déjà fait et c'est
là qu'on en est premier problème
deuxième problème le ministère fédéral
de l'immigration dans son fonctionnement
et là on ne parle pas seulement du
Québec semble être complètement dépassé
par les événements ou même par les sites
d'immigration qui ont été fixées par le
gouvernement de Monsieur Trudeau c'est
un ministère qui va pas bien et ça va
nuire aussi bien à François Legault que
possible d'immigration du gouvernement
fédéral mais c'est pas un sujet de
négociation je pense que la personne la
plus heureuse hier c'était Dominique
Leblanc c'est le ministre fédéral des
Affaires intergouvernementales qui a dit
Hey François Legault vient de dire
différemment ce que je dis c'est à dire
utiliser vos pouvoirs existants jusqu'à
la limite plutôt que de venir négocier
sur la réunification des familles et les
grands mamans qui parlent pas français
et ça c'était un quand même un
changement de ton Michelet pour mais pas
juste un changement de ton changement de
demande de la part de Monsieur le Gaulle
mais c'est beaucoup plus porteur parce
que se battre sur la réunification des
familles ça ne donnait rien à la fin là
c'est de l'humanitaire alors le Québec
aurait fait la même chose que ta voix a
peu de choses près c'est pas vrai
chantal a raison qu'on va dire à une
grand-maman qui ne parle pas français
vous ne pouvez pas voir vos
petits-enfants et puis ça fait pas de
sens alors là on est dans d'autres
choses et c'est un fait que comme
militant pour la population le chemin
Roxane est quelque chose de très gros
cela dit
le chemin Roxane ça se règle avec une
entente avec les États-Unis et ils ont
pas l'air très proches de bouger
là-dessus alors on peut se plaindre
beaucoup on peut peut-être demander des
sous parce que c'était un fait que
Québec a des dépenses qui doivent être
compensées mais pensez qu'on va régler
le problème du chemin Roxane à court
terme ça me semble être un petit peu
trop mais c'est une revendication
Véronique plus claire du Québec plus
circonscrite plutôt que de dire on veut
tous les pouvoirs de tout après tout
c'est de dire régler le chemin relaxant
on a changé on met la pression ailleurs
en fait ce changement d'approche on
passe d'une approche idéaliste qui est
de dire on veut rapatrier tous les
pouvoirs à une approche plus pragmatique
de dire on va faire notre bout de chemin
on va mettre de l'eau dans notre vin on
va voir ce que nous on peut faire de
notre côté par exemple avec les
étudiants étrangers on pourrait mieux
choisir notre immigration il y avait
avec des travailleurs temporaires qui
sont déjà installés ici qui ont fait
leur cercle social et tout ça bon
maintenant on fait notre bout de chemin
ça va tour de le faire c'est un peu
l'approche que le gouvernement logo va
faire et à quelque part on va peut-être
finir par se rejoindre de cette façon là
néanmoins si on peut pas renégocier
l'entente en passant on pourrait
peut-être convaincre qu'ils étaient unis
et le Canada d'installer un poste
français à officiel c'est un peu ça que
sur ton train de faire sans le nom si ça
l'était un poste français officiel le
l'entend s'applique on s'entend
c'est installer une guérite des deux
côtés avec des gardes frontières puis on
est dans l'entente
pas contents on les refoule parce que
sur les Américains ok santé aujourd'hui
monsieur Trudeau c'était le marqueur du
début de cette nouvelle politique pour
les soins dentaires les 12 ans et moins
les parents seront aidés et remboursés
pour les soins dentaires des enfants
partout au Canada au Québec ça touche
quand même un peu les gens parce que 10
ans et moins remboursé donc il y a deux
ans où on va étendre le programme on va
aider à éteindre le programme alors
monsieur Legault hier que je fais
entendre sur la santé c'est demande à
Monsieur Trudeau et Monsieur Trudeau
aujourd'hui on lui a posé la question
vous avez de l'argent pour les dents
pourquoi pas régler la santé d'abord on
écoute
il est temps qu'on s'assoit les premiers
ministres des provinces des territoires
avec le premier ministre du Canada puis
qu'on règle ce dossier là on est
raisonnable on dit fédéral devrait
passer de 22% des dépenses de santé à
35% des dépenses de santé quand on dit
qu'il y a 40 % de nos impôts qui vont à
Ottawa ben je pense que 35% des dépenses
en santé ça serait juste normal on n'a
pas besoin plus de conditions ce qu'on a
besoin c'est que le fédéral face enfin
ça juste pas
[Applaudissements]
oui les Canadiens sont inquiets par
rapport à nos systèmes de santé à
travers le pays la réalité c'est que
nous il y a beaucoup de familles qui
sont très préoccupés par l'accès à leurs
enfants à des systèmes de soins de
qualité et nous aussi nous sommes
préoccupés c'est pour ça que nous avons
investi 72 milliards de dollars de plus
au cours des dernières années avec la
pandémie mais pourquoi nous travaillons
maintenant avec les provinces pour
exiger de meilleurs résultats pour les
Canadiens
un petit peu plus compliqué cette
négociation là bon la dernière fois le
monsieur Trudeau avait dit ils ont
refusé ils auraient pas dû on leur avait
offert plein de choses Michelet
négociation qui va traîner on le sent
encore plusieurs mois
plusieurs mois aussi écoutez ça fait
depuis le début de du mandat de
jean-chrétiens que le gouvernement
fédéral veut avoir
des rapports veut avoir des données
qu'il va qu'il va préparer qui va dire
voici les données qu'on veut en échange
duquel il pourrait peut-être donner plus
d'argent aux provinces de prendre
nationale 60 et puis ensuite la
commission Romano pour ça les provinces
disent ok on va vous donner si on vous
donne tous ces renseignements-là vous
allez qui va prendre des décisions après
c'est des fonctionnaires à tawa qui ont
jamais géré un hôpital et c'est ça qu'on
veut pas et on est dans cette même
impasse là depuis quelque chose comme 25
ans alors il y a rien de bébé nouveau
là-dedans ce qui est nouveau c'est que
quand il y a une situation comme
maintenant des virus respiratoires qui
s'attaquent surtout aux enfants dans
tout le pays les les les hôpitaux de
tout le pays sont en train de d'éclater
alors un moment donné on n'est pas dans
quel genre de renseignement vous nous
donnez on est dans l'urgence Chantal
en fait c'est vrai qu'on en parle depuis
25 ans ou 30 ans et grâce aux gens
chrétiens mais il faut se rappeler que
les problèmes en santé ont commencé
comme le gouvernement fédéral je suis
pas le Martin a trouvé que c'était une
bonne idée de ralentir l'augmentation
des transferts aux provinces en santé
pour équilibrer le budget Monsieur
Martin monsieur chrétien ont récolté les
lauriers et les provinces se sont
retrouvées avec une crise qui perdure
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pourquoi je dis
qu'ils sont condamnés à s'entendre et en
particulier dans le code Justin Trudeau
parce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui un sondage
nanos qui était quelque part étonnant
parce que ce qu'il montre c'est que les
la priorité des Canadiens de l'inflation
s'est déplacée sur l'accès aux soins de
santé
oh monsieur Trudeau va aller aux urnes
avant monsieur Legault avant monsieur
Ford avant à peu près tout le monde qui
va être autour de la table avec lui et
ce que sondage là montrer aussi c'est
qui vous blâmer pour la situation
actuelle et la réponse c'était tout le
monde tous les gouvernements alors
quelque part quand le premier ministre
du Canada dit j'exige des meilleurs
soins de santé c'est comme s'il faisait
semblant de pas s'apercevoir que tout le
monde essayait de faire son possible
parce qu'il y en a pas de gouvernement
provincial au Canada qui est assis en se
disant on va laisser une crise perdurer
pour avoir plus d'argent pour la santé
oui et ce n'est pas qu'au Québec c'est
partout au Canada en Alberta ils ont
construit une aile à un hôpital aussi
pour enfants tellement que ça déborde
partout Véronique
à suivre donc mais là-dessus monsieur
Legault garde le cap il y a pas eu de
changement de stratégie là-dessus c'est
clair et net là on veut que la part du
fédéral augmente
en même temps vous avez vu que le ton
était peut-être un petit peu différent
aussi quand elle a rencontré directement
Justin Trudeau en Tunisie on sentait que
le ton était un petit peu plus
chaleureux à ce moment-là Justin Trudeau
complimentait le fait qu'il sort du B
déjà créé son système de données et puis
François Legault de son côté fermait pas
complètement la porte justement à
partager certaines des données même si
Christian Dubé dit ben on en a mis
public sur nos sites Web quand les voir
à cet endroit là en fait j'ai
l'impression que chacun de leur côté ils
ont l'impression d'avoir le gros bout du
bâton au Québec on se dit tout le monde
voit que nos urgences ont un problème
que ça déborde tout le monde voit qu'on
manque d'argent alors tout le monde
comprend que ta voix doit en donner plus
Ottawa de son côté dit justement tout le
monde voit que ça fonctionne pas dans le
système de santé au Québec notamment
alors tout le monde comprend pourquoi on
veut mettre des conditions donc chacun
pense avoir raison de son côté et ça
fait pas vraiment avancer pendant ce
temps-là les négociations
très bien mais vous avez raison le
souligner en Tunisie monsieur Trudeau
qui a souligné
que les indicateurs de Monsieur Duby
c'est un peu ça monsieur le gars oui
mais c'est public là aller sur notre
site bon bref
l'Alberta Chantal Michel C rapidement et
claire et nous mais on va entendre très
rapidement monsieur Trudeau
la loi sur la souveraineté de l'Alberta
dans un Canada uni on écoute
certainement qu'on regarde attentivement
ce qui est proposé par par l'Alberta je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'albertin qui
expriment déjà leur préoccupation par le
fait que le gouvernement de l'Alberta a
été en train de choisir de d'aller
autour de la législature de dévaloriser
le travail des parlementaires on va
regarder tout d'abord ce que les
Albertins vont dire ils vont faire
eux-mêmes idéalement ça va être des
albertin eux-mêmes qui vont se
préoccuper avec les nouveaux pouvoirs
exceptionnels que la première ministre
s'est donné
la première ministre qui s'est donné
dans une projet de loi le pouvoir si
toute l'assemblée d'accord Chantal de
contourner des lois fédérales du
urbanous on s'occupe plus de ça on a ça
va tenir quoi le temps que ce
gouvernement leur tient Chantal en
Alberta
en gros oui en fait c'est le pouvoir
d'écrire unilatéralement des lois
provinciales pour répondre aux fédéral
sans passer par l'Assemblée législatives
de l'alberto ce qui est quand même
particulier il a imaginé François
Legault qui dit j'irai pas à l'Assemblée
nationale je vais écrire des lois
si Justin Trudeau s'embarquait dans une
bataille rangée là-dessus il serait
comme un ours à qui on montre un piège
en lui disant mais dont ta tête dedans
en gros ce que Damien Smith souhaite le
plus la première ministre alberté
bouge parce que elle pourrait faire sa
campagne électorale au printemps en
disant je fais campagne quand Justin
Trudeau très populaire en Alberta la
sagesse c'est de laisser passer de
laisser le temps au temps et de se
rendre à la campagne électorale il y a
de notre lit l'ancienne Première
ministre qui est la chef de l'opposition
en avance dans les sondages qui dit
exactement ça qui est Monsieur Trudeau
regardez ça encore de loin pour créer
une tisane la même qu'avec monsieur
Legault en Tunisie Michel C
je trouve ça me fait penser à la loi 99
au Québec ou qui était conçu pour
littéralement provoquer le gouvernement
fédéral il va juste dit non je ferai pas
ça et quand la décision de la Cour
d'appel du Québec est arrivé tout le
monde a dit c'est parfait monsieur la
médecine a dit ça le gouvernement du
Québec a dit ça puis personne n'est allé
en cours alors
strictement pour l'esbrooke comme ça là
ça donne ce que ça donne vous savez on
va finir on va boucler à boucle c'est
une
assez longtemps je trouve la politique
savoir c'est quoi un coût publicitaire
ça ça en était un serment on voit ça en
était un puis tout est on boucle la
boucle avec les couples publicitaires
merci à vous trois à très bientôt au
revoir merci au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]